[Music]
my cousin who lives in Hong Kong is a
game programmer and he loves what I'm
doing but he just tells me when we
discuss it I need immediate
gratification like he codes something
and he sees a game character do
something cool right and if you need
that if you really need to see something
cool happen every day AGI is not for you
and in AGI you may work six months and
nothing interesting happens and then
something really really interesting
happens so I think if someone doesn't
have that kind of stubborn pigheaded
persistence I will tend to employ them
doing for example data analysis because
that gives immediate gratification you
get a data set from a customer you run a
machine learning algorithm on it and you
get a result which is interesting the
customer is happy then you go on to the
to the next data set and if you explain
the different types of work available
actually most people are pretty good at
choosing what won't drive them crazy so
some people are like yeah what I want to
do stuff that seems cool every day and
other people are like well I I really
want to understand you know how thinking
works I want to understand how cognition
and vision work together and that's much
more interesting to me than applying an
existing vision algorithm to solve solve
someone's problem so I I tend to I tend
to throw the issue at the potential
employee or volunteer themselves and
sometimes that works sometimes it
doesn't but I trust them to know
themselves better than I know them
anyway there are many different types
and levels of problem
the one encounters in in doing AI work
and there are sort of low-level
algorithmic problems or software design
problems what you solved via clever
tricks and then there are deeper
problems like how do you architect a
perception system how should perception
and cognition work together in an AI
system if a system knows one language
how do you leverage that knowledge ah
but learn another language I find
personally with these deeper problems
this is the kind of thing you solve
while you're like walking the dog in the
forester or taking a shower or driving
down down the highway or something and
seems to me that the people who make
headway on these deeper problems have
the personality type that carries the
problem in their head all the times like
you'll think about this thing when you
go to sleep you're still thinking about
it when you woke up and you just keep
chewing on this issue a hundred times a
day it could be for days or weeks or
years or or even decades and then the
solution pop pops pops up for you and
not everyone has the inclination or
personality to be obsessive it sort of
keeping a problem like an egg in your
mind and your focus and until the
solution the solution hatches out but
that that's a particular cognitive style
or habit or skill which I see in
everyone I know who's really making
headway on the AGI problem
you